the beta for ps4 firmware update 5.50
has begun which means we're getting a
peek at new features I'm Tony and this
GameSpot news update has some new tricks
up its sleeve the changes start with the
cross media bar the library tab has been
divided into two sections one for
everything you purchased and another for
what's actually installed on your ps4 it
also has a specific group for PS Plus
games you've claimed you can now import
any custom background via USB with some
limited options for zooming and cropping
a new playtime management option has
also been introduced
this is an ideal feature for parents
wanting to limit their kids gaming time
you'll be able to track daily use of the
console and set time limits through the
console itself a PC and even your
smartphone the Quick Menu has seen some
changes too with new options for
controlling music playback and accessing
certain friends those changes are for
all ps4 s but the pro specifically will
see some updates as well a new super
sampling feature is available for users
without a 4k TV allowing for greater
clarity with certain games it's a nice
compliment to the buffed up consoles
boost mode Sony hasn't announced a
public date for version 5.50 yet but if
you want to keep up with all the biggest
PlayStation news you can use the
official game spot now app to browse our
top stories that's available on iOS and
Android
[Music]